joe ryan has made quite an impression of
his first two appearances in the big
leagues he's done a great job of only
one walk he's been aggressive with that
fastball he's throwing it more than
league average mile straw picked up a
whole bunch of singles against the twins
last week first pitch lifted to left and
ref schneider makes the catch and joe
ryan will take all of those he can get
softly to the third baseman
so far so good
three pitches
two outs and that'll bring up jose
ramirez
fly ball right field
kepler puts it away six pitches a one
two three first tristan uh coming off a
loss to the minnesota twins in that last
game that they pitched but on the road
he has three out of his four wins this
year
swings at the first pitch and
lifts it to center field miles straw
camps under it one down under rocco ball
deli has byron buxton in the two-hole
good breaking ball to strike him out two
away
that ball is rope to right field right
at zimmer tell you what these two
lineups they've come out swinging the
bat
no score after one
so two down no score and here comes
harold ramirez right-handed batting left
fielder a waiver claim
from the marlins back in february
slowed it down he yanks it down the line
it's a fair ball hit it to the wall
and big harold will roll into second
base with his 21st double of the year uh
you talk about the location here you'll
see he misses his location he he left
the spinner in the middle of the plate
two down now zimmer
change up got him so the doubles wasted
left at second base another scoreless
inning for joe ryan since the all-star
break kepler is batting under 200.
and kepler takes his walk to start the
second inning
high cheddar threw it right by him and
strikes him out second k for mackenzie
one down
[Music]
adam got him picked him off he got him
he got caught leaning he was gonna take
off they threw over there so whoever's
calling that throw to first base did the
right thing
oh boy that's scary when you're you know
you're done
bradley gets him on the forearm before
he gets the hand back in they're not
gonna challenge that much the tag on the
forearm oh yeah
hedges jimenez and straw
and the swing of the miss puts him away
second straight strikeout for ryan
got him looking
three straight strikeouts for ryan
bottom third of the order for minnesota
here in the third rob ref snyder leads
it off
oh got him looking stayed right with
that slider the hole at that third
strikeout for mckenzie is it going to be
moving
spanx one sharply into right field he's
got a single
and zimmer fires it back in first twins
hit
comes with one out here in the third
here's simmons good hit run guy
that's to left
and into a slide for some reason ramirez
will let it get to the wall rortfett can
run pretty well he'll come around third
and head home and score the first run of
the game good throw and watch this as
you said maybe an ill-advised diving
attempt here but
once this ball got past him
he got up
and got rid of that ball quickly not a
great throw
nice job by ximena's they're picking
that ball and then feed it to the play
and that's going to be really close i'm
assuming
if they're taking a look at it maybe
they thought he was out but i don't know
how that's going to be overturned in
first look it's a no-brainer to
challenge and see if he can get it
overturned safe is the call
so rorfett scores from first on the
simmons double
and the twins get that all-important
first run in a seven inning game we get
a two out base hit right here buxton
bats
up the ladder he goes with a good high
fastball to end the inning four k's for
mckenzie but minnesota is on the board
first and here's franmil reyes
breaking ball got him another strikeout
two down to the bottom the fourth
for minnesota it'll be polanco kepler
and ceneaux the hitters due up
mckenzie delivers swung on and missed
strikeout number five for the
right-hander ryan's been in control
throughout it had stopped bouncing and
rolling and was just sitting on my stack
ramirez bradley zimmer struck out his
only time up
delivery oh he got him
bradley zimmer slams the bat as he slams
one to the upper tank
and we are tied at one
seventh home run of the year for zimmer
rbi number 30.
and just the second home run that joe
ryan has allowed and 16 plus innings of
work
it looked like zimmer was mad
he threw that bat down and he said uh
about time he got that i think it was a
changeup let's take a look and see
it was he elevated that he struck him
out on the changeup but he got this one
up
and he just tosses that bat down to the
ground so we have a new ball game
okay well when bradley zimmer hits him
he hits him a long way word vet to bat
the 2-2
blew it by him look at him that's a nice
quick inning right there for mckenzie
eight pitches he retires a one two three
eight straight set down by the right
hand mile straw leads it off top of the
order here in the sixth
oh man right back at him he's hurt yeah
he is hurt i think
or he's stunned one or the other he's
walking off yeah i got him on the hand
that's why he he wasn't going to go
after and i'm sure he could right on the
wrist rick you can see a big
bump on that wrist right he's walking
right off the wow that's a shame
oh man
he didn't say a word to anybody
and i mean that ball yeah he is
frustrated he is up into the trainer's
room now
and i mean he couldn't get out of the
way he thought he had the glove there
once he sees it he knew nope i'm not
even going to go out i mean look at the
knot immediately
above the right just above the right
wrist we're gonna have to get that x-ray
oh
and the pitch a swinging a line drive
into left center field this one's back
deep towards the wall and in plane off
the top of the wall doubleton the second
base he will glide in standing one pitch
one swing and it's a pinch hit double
and he got him
back with that slider
tristan owns him man i'll tell you what
he is
what a job he has done seventh strikeout
of the day
cleveland has three hits one of the
three from the batter right now harold
ramirez a double off ryan earlier ground
ball up the middle to his right polacco
misses it
so just into the ball game and polanco
will be charged with an error
missed outside ball four
so two on and one out and austin hedges
coming to the plate
left field it's deep it's near the line
it is a fair ball off the wall
scoring the go ahead run as harold
ramirez in the third as zimmer it's an
rbi double for austin hedges and the
indians have a 2-1 lead well he was
aggressive and got after that first
fastball and i mean he put it hit him
right on the nose off the wall this is
going to be you chang
and a ground ball single off the third
baseman arise another run is in it's 3-1
cleveland as zimmer comes home
and into third base went austin hedges
they have a three to one lead and
they're going to hand it over to
emmanuel classe
broke his back and lines it to you chang
book it the indians are back in the win
column they stop their three-game losing
streak with a series opening win
against the minnesota twins by a final
score of 3-1
you